let's answer some questions from the
audience there's some really really good
questions this week and if you're
watching you probably are already
wondering why there's a picture of Kyle
kolinsky from secular talk up on my
screen that's because the first question
today is from key shows that hey David
it cracked when I got this question it
cracked me up Keshia said hey David is
Kyle cool in skis New York accent a
problem I love this question a problem
for who would be by question and maybe
what I don't know what Keshia is
alluding to there are many media hosts
who make an effort to sort of
delocalized their accent and opt for
what is often seen as the more generic
media accent is in the United States
which is sort of a blend of a Midwest
northeast in California right sort of
the areas that have not they don't speak
the same way in all those areas but
they're considered sort of more standard
and they believe that will appeal to the
broadest amount of people exactly and
yes there's no doubt that when you
listen to Kyle he has a New York accent
although I my opinion is that it's
lessened significantly over the last few
years and I have a funny story about
this which I don't think Kyle will mind
me telling if he even remembers about
this if I found it really funny it might
not have made an impression on him the
first time I met Kyle Cole in ski in
person we got together in at a Manhattan
coffee shop named COPI kopi close to NYU
which was a spot I would have a lot of
meetings at and just hang out pretty
frequently at when I lived in New York
City and at a certain point you know we
were just chatting about different
things and I said something to him like
hey are you do you actively try to not
speak with a New York accent on your
show and he genuinely it was he in
complete honesty and innocence he said
to me oh I have a New York accent right
as if he had no idea whatsoever that
that's a way he spoke which is actually
not that rare when you talk to people
who grow up grew up in a particular area
if you're completely used to hearing
people talk in a particular way you in a
way become sort of death to that way of
talking and
the first time I met Kyle and I think at
the time he had a much more notable New
York accent than than he has now I
immediately noticed that he clearly
talked differently than me and
differently than my friends from
Massachusetts or whatever and he
genuinely didn't know what I was talking
about and I said oh no I mean I'm not
I'm not saying anything I'm just saying
it is noticeable that you have a New
York accent
and there are people like Howard Stern
for example who has made an effort who's
from Long Island to get rid of the
accent and it in a lot of ways he has
although he still says horrible instead
of horrible and Florida instead of
Florida and you hear it with some words
and I don't know if this is even that
that big of a thing anymore increasingly
when you have sort of a global or
national media landscape people's
accents tend to become sort of more
average in every way I mean I think just
the way that Kyle isn't polished in the
same way that someone on more
traditional platforms of news would be
will come across as someone who's gone
through training to get rid of their
accent that makes them look more genuine
and I think that's what appeals to more
people
hard to say that Kyle is not genuine in
what he said so I love the question from
Keshia to answer the the original
question is Kyle kolinsky New York
accent the problem I would say it
doesn't seem to be a problem at least
for secular talk